but everybody wants to overlook that
phenomenal message that these men are
dying to hear he didn't entertain didn't
go to these people houses and like kick
down their doors like you better
subscribe me to YouTube you little beta
male no there's a vacuum of desolate
broken men who are looking for a
masculine leader and he filled the
vacuum and he was the one with this
empowering message and a lot of these
guys have turned their lives around and
that's why he got canceled why because
the elites want slaves they want good
obedient stupid slaves smart enough to
do the work but dumb enough not to ask
why am I a Slave